[Musique]
les jb continue tranquillement leur
route vers la terre et s'arrêtent de
temps en temps pour visiter le cosmo le
cosmos est peut-être un peu comme une
campagne ordinaire sauf que
naturellement tout était cosmique
il y avait des arbres cosmique début du
poids cosmique des casques akg au smic
et des quantités de choses cosmique
comme ça et puis un jour on rentre et
ils s'aperçurent qu'il y avait un gie
bidi manque
il était plus simplement rester dans les
champs cosmique à s'amuser
[Musique]
il disait que lui les histoires de
voyages de refuge et de planètes tout ça
ça l'intéressait pas que lui il voulait
vivre sa vie de j j et qu'il voulait
rester ici mais le malheureux avait
perdu son chapeau le chapeau des jbe
vous le savez ça leur servait à
réfléchir et un jbe qui avait perdu son
chapeau pratiquement c'était un gimmick
avait perdu la tête
il avait fallu le faire rentrer de force
lille c'est fini a tout saccagé dans la
rue et ils se faisaient de la soupe avec
les réserves de graines de gyroscopes et
deux moteurs électriques et ils se
mettaient à tourner à tourner soit
disant pour faire de l'électricité pour
le faire tenir tranquille on l'asseyait
devant la télévision et il regardait les
shadoks
aussi bizarre que cela paraisse ça le
calmer mais c'était quand même pas une
solution
l'important c'était de lui retrouver son
chapeau mais où avait il bien pu
l'oublier
[Musique]